Rescuers
why am I here Roman I need you we're
gonna destroy their whole nuclear
program
you know the risk trust me
please be safe will you okay
oh my God
hot sauce just came through the CIA is
Target's an Iranian nuclear facilities
our covers blood we're leaving 15
minutes
distraction point
to the CIA base you can't have problems
just want to go home and I'll be with
you
the distance is not the main issue
that's what's in between
they didn't even catch my guy we'll sell
them to the highest bidder there will be
no sanctity for you
raise your hands
do it before they get Trigger Happy
[Music]
we didn't get it
please
[Music]
tell me what's truly going on we cut
outs in an even bigger game this is my
life in your hands
[Music]
no one is coming to rescue us
sorry
for everything
[Music]
foreign